before the pandemic Australia was a
popular destination for Chinese
Travelers and they are expected to
return soon as China prepares to open
its borders for the first time in almost
three years but from Thursday they'll
face new restrictions
the government has decided out of an
abundance of caution to require
travelers from China to submit evidence
before boarding their flight of a
negative covert test
Canada the United States United Kingdom
Japan India and South Korea will also
screen passengers from China in Europe
France Italy and Spain will do the same
and are encouraging other EU Nations to
follow suit Morocco has taken the
hardest line banning all Chinese
travelers from Tuesday many fear the
outbreak here could lead to a new
coronavirus strain and sparked New Waves
of infections globally Beijing has hit
back at the restrictions calling them
unscientific
many leading medical experts from
multiple countries have said that there
is no need to impose restrictions on
Boulder entry of travelers from China
the World Health Organization says it's
understandable governments want to
protect their populations it is asked
for more real-time data on deaths
hospitalization and strains Beijing says
it isn't withholding any information
from the who but with only a dozen
covid-19 deaths reported in recent weeks
scientists suspect
underreporting of infections some
estimates suggest that there could be as
many as nine thousand deaths occurring
every day
katrinau Al Jazeera Beijing